Greg Olson is ready the Seattle Seahawks
ounds strange to say that the Seattle
Seahawks tight and former Panthers I in
originally drafted by the Bears joining
us on the program you know what I saw
the news Greg I was wondering is this to
play for a championship again to get
back to a Super Bowl or is this just
playing another season you know I think
you always want to put yourself in the
best position to you know play
meaningful games and contending could be
but yeah I think it's so hard if you set
out every year and you just tried to
pick a team solely based on winning the
Super Bowl I mean it'd be like winning
the lottery there's so many factors so
many teams before the season look great
so many season so many teams every year
kind of surprised yet you know I was
looking for consistency wasn't you know
what teams have played at a high level
for a long time and Seattle's at the top
of that list with a you know Bonilla and
full of other teams and the fact that
they were as interested as they were
combined with all those other factors I
mentioned you know it gives you a chance
how the season goes this time will tell
but you know you're always going to be
in the mix with a guy like Russell and a
system in an organization like that and
that was appealing to me do you call
Russell Wilson or do you wait for him to
call you we've talked quite a bit we we
connected shortly after answers notified
me of my release the weekend of Super
Bowl and got together and spend some
time and he's been also we've had really
good dialogue through this whole process
you know we talked about where to send
kids to school and we've talked about
you know different source of offense and
different thoughts of how they have used
the tight end in the past and some
things that I've had success with that
maybe they haven't implemented so we've
we've covered a lot of ground and he's
super impressive he's super engaged he's
you know he operates pretty much
everything he does at a really high
level and it's been fun to you know
really get to know him through this
process how scary is retirement you know
I don't know I don't know I'm probably
not far off
but you know I think the unknown and
given up on what you've done your whole
life I think it's scary but I also think
you know when that time comes I'm gonna
be ready for it you know I I wasn't sure
what this year was going to bring and if
the opportunities weren't out there I
was going to be very content moving on
but I still wanted to play I still knew
I could play but um it's definitely a
transition that a lot of guys chase and
it's inevitable and I'll let you know
when I get there how did the fans in
Seattle treat you in the number of times
I think you might have played there five
times maybe six times how do they treat
you is awesome I mean they are loud they
are I mean they're energetic you know
arguably the best best home environment
you know in the entire league we played
playoff games up there we played a lot
of great regular-season games there in
15 we had like an all-time classic game
it's uh it's a unique and really special
fan base and stadium and environment and
I'm just hopefully that I can do some
things that now they'll be cheering for
me instead of making my life miserable
on the other side these these Seahawks
tight end Greg Olson joining us on the
program what are you going to do with
all your Carolina gear I guess I could
follow around to Ron's kind of yarn sale
but you know and I told the kids they
you know we're still Charlotte people
we're going to live here in town when
when my career is done at some point you
know will be Panther fans will go to
games will support the team you know we
still obviously have our roots the kids
have lived almost their whole lives here
in in Charlotte so it will never lose
that this is not like we're going to
disappear off the face of the earth to
never come back we're we're Charlotte
Carolina people we've loved raising our
kids here we've loved growing up here
and building our family so we're not
going to cheer for them too much this
year but I got some really good buddies
on the team that
obviously I want them to do well but you
know we're all in on Seattle right now
and you know we're going to give them
everything we have to try to be the best
asset we can to that entire organization
and see what it brings us what's going
on with the Carolina Panthers we had
Christian McCaffrey on at the Superbowl
and I said are you rebuilding and he
said yes yeah you know I think I think
that's where all the signs are pointing
you know I obviously nobody's going to
come right out and say that that's kind
of a taboo world the taboo word that
world but you know I think they're
fortunate they do have a lot of good
players still you know guys like
Christian obviously we'll see what
happens with Cam if they bring him back
they'll always have a chance but uh but
if I if I said let me let me listen to
let me hear from analyst Greg Olson not
former player what do you think Carolina
should do at the quarterbacking position
it depends they want to win I think it
really comes down to is your
organization content on not winning this
year to improve drastic draft capital
future draft picks if you don't want to
win then you don't bring Cam Newton back
if you want to win and you want to
compete from day one then you bring Cam
Newton back so I think it really it's a
super easy decision once they make their
Filipino once their philosophy and their
approach is settled and I don't know
whether that has been or not but once
that is I think then the decision with
Cam really just marries up with
whichever path the organization wants to
take for the 2020 season
yeah I'm right there with you I feel the
same way just because they came out and
said you know we want him back
I don't think cam is gonna be the
starting quarterback for Carolina when
this season starts I just I you're gone
Luke Kuechly retires
can we not sure about new coach new
offensive coordinator new owner in there
just feels like time for sweeping
changes in McCaffrey you're not going to
get up get rid of so you kind of build
around him but I just can't see cam as a
starting quarterback
yeah which is unfortunate but as I kind
of alluded to at the end of the season
kind of saw the writing on the walls it
pertained to be sometimes change just
leads to more change and it doesn't mean
it's good or bad it just it is and you
know if they're going to if they're
going to start fresh on all those other
things maybe they decide that it's time
to start fresh on everything but again
we won't know until that decision is
made and I don't know when that you know
I've kind of obviously lost a lot of
insight and the a lot of the people that
you know we had kind of grown with that
organization to the last nine years have
kind of moved on to other places so I
wish those guys nothing but your great
success have a lot of respect for that
rule had a chance to spend a lot of time
with him over the last you know his
first couple weeks on the job and was
really impressed with his vision and his
his expertise and building things and
whatnot so I think those guys will
figure it out I just you know I don't
know if anybody understands right now
the timetable that they're operating on
a number of high-profile players like JJ
Watt Aaron Rodgers Russell Wilson are no
rush to sign this new CBA what's what's
the big concern you know that's a good
question I think you know I think what
happens a lot of times is you know guys
see it through the lens of how it
affects them and I think that's human
nature and I don't I don't blame anybody
you know guys that are at the later
stage in their career you know post
retirement benefits and you know what it
means for me in my post playing days
that's a huge factor if I'm a young guy
and my first year - and I'm kind of on
the on the fence I'm a borderline roster
guy I'm trying to make as much as I can
in the shortest period of time that I
can because I don't know how long my
career is going to be and then there's
all these guys kind of in the middle
that are kind of in flux they're just
kind of in the meat of their careers and
they're kind of being pulled in each
direction so I think anytime you're
trying to find a deal that works for
1,200 guys that are all different
situations and different economics and
priorities it's it's hard for twelve
hundred to negotiate against 30
one you know and it's just it's just a
tough situation I remember going through
it back in 2011 I'm one of the few guys
that went through the last CBA and now
it's obviously still playing for this
CBA and we went through a lot of these
same arguments that shamed back and
forth in 2011 and we find ourselves you
know nine years later kind of do it at
all again I'll leave you with this when
you get to Seattle I got one tip for you
all right
don't take your shirt off around DK
Medcalf I actually played in Chicago
with DK Matt Capps father so that's how
this will be the first time in my career
that I will play with a father and son
his father was Terrence Metcalf he was
one of our offensive linemen in Chicago
my first year or so it's up there and
hey congratulations good luck with that
move there and we'll keep in touch thank
you Greg Greg Olson now with the Seattle
Seahawks for more Dan Patrick show tune
in to audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
stream for free on be our live or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]